the surprising car technology that's no
longer available the family member that
is shockingly missing the jaw-dropping
decision that affects the entire plot
most 90s kids loved a goofy movie
growing up but there are things only
adults noticed
max's dream girl roxanne is portrayed as
attractive and sweet throughout a goofy
movie and both kids and adults will
notice that the movie goes out of its
way to ensure the audience understands
that max has it bad for her what kids
may not notice but adults surely will is
just how alluring roxanne is in max's
mind in fact adults will recognize that
in the first scene where max meets
roxanne in a field she's been highly
sexualized complete with a revealing
dress a come-hither expression and
plenty of sexy poses and when it's
revealed that the scene is part of max's
dream adults will realize that it's max
objectifying his crush this may be a
kid's movie but it portrays its
protagonist as a hormonal teen boy who
despite being awkward and nervous when
he talks to roxanne has feelings toward
her that aren't that innocent even
though adults may find this slightly
amusing kids are unlikely to notice just
how on the nose the film is about max's
adolescent urges
there are many big names behind the
voices of the characters in a goofy
movie but kids and even many younger
adults are unlikely to realize it the
most noteworthy actors were at the
height of their popularity when the film
came out including jason marsden kelly
martin and jenna von oy marsden
continues to work as an in-demand voice
actor today but at the time he also
appeared in sitcoms like full house boy
meets world and step by step meanwhile
although they still regularly star in
movies and tv in the 90s martin was
known for her role in the drama life
goes on and van oy for playing mayam
bialik's best friend in the comedy
blossom yet the most well-known member
of the cast was paulie shore an actor
and stand-up comedian who was a mega
star in the 90s due to a hit mtv show in
films like encino man and biodome
[Music]
in fact sure was so popular when a goofy
movie was made that his work as the
voice of cheese whiz loving slacker
bobby zimaruski went uncredited while
those who grew up in the 90s are still
likely to recognize his distinct
delivery as bobby anyone younger
probably won't realize that shaw is the
actor behind the character's stylized
voice
you know maybe max isn't all the things
that you think a son should be but
he loves me hey my son respects me
goofy's co-worker pete is the type to
take candy from a baby and he believes
the only way to parent is to keep strict
control over his son but he's not
exactly a villain yet while kids won't
think much of his presence in the film
adults familiar with walt disney's
career will know that pete has been
causing trouble in disney productions
for almost 100 years pete first appeared
as an antagonist in 1925 in one of
disney's live-action animated hybrid
alice comedies he went on to play the
villain of oswald the lucky rabbit and
when disney lost the rights to that
character he was the villain of mickey
mouse throughout the 1930s pete made
numerous appearances in mickey mouse
shorts he was often a rival to mickey
for the affections of minnie mouse who
he tended to kidnap in an awful attempt
to win her over at the time pete was
frequently drawn with a wooden peg in
place of one of his legs leading to his
nickname pegleg pete the character went
on to appear in short's opposite other
famous disney characters including goofy
who made his first screen appearance in
1932. pete continues to pop up in disney
projects to this day so although his
villainous tendencies are muted in a
goofy movie he always has new
opportunities to go bad in the company's
latest movies shows video games or other
projects
a goofy movie tends to get very meta
very often with disney easter eggs
popping up throughout the film given how
well known all things disney are to kids
and adults both are likely to catch many
of these moments kids will have no
problem noticing max's mickey mouse
phone when goofy guesses walt disney as
the answer during a card game between
him and max they'll easily spot the
times when the character ariel from the
little mermaid shows up on a piece of
theater scenery early in the film or as
a lamp at the hotel goofy and max stop
at later but the movie also includes
some more subtle easter eggs that only
adults are likely to notice for instance
adults will probably realize that the d
that appears on goofy's keychain uses
the font of the disney logo and that
goofy uses a bambi stuffed animal to get
a little girl to laugh for a photo plus
adults who are familiar with goofy from
before goof troop are likely to
recognize that his terrible
demonstration of how to make the perfect
cast when teaching max how to fish is
reminiscent of the character's hilarious
how-to shorts
dad you ruined it
sorry about that
was he anyway it's only power powerline
dad the biggest rock star on the planet
the pop star power line is a catalyst
for many of max's ill-advised actions in
a goofy movie and in the climax of the
film max and goofy end up dancing with
powerline on stage at his los angeles
concert the movie's director kevin lima
has said that the inspiration for the
pop star character came from noted
musicians of the time including prince
michael jackson and bobby brown today
kids may not even notice those
influences when watching power line
scenes many adults on the other hand may
find that powerline reminds them of some
popular rock stars of the 70s too in
particular powerline has a very specific
stage persona that seems to speak to a
combination of 70s era david bowie and
devo the singer wears a yellow jumpsuit
reminiscent of a hazmat suit which is
very similar to one of devo's most
well-known costumes from the 1970s
moreover the way david bowie adopted and
committed to onstage personas in the
1970s especially during his ziggy
stardust era speaks to the persona power
line embodies in the film in fact
according to leymah bowie's commitment
to alter egos for his performances was
exactly where the idea for powerline's
theatrical identity including the atom
symbol that became his logo came from
from their first interaction in a goofy
movie it's clear goofy and max aren't on
the same page goofy seems oblivious to
the friction between them telling pete
that max is a good kid even as pete
loudly registers his skepticism but
after max pulls a prank to woo his crush
roxanne at a school assembly and his
principal calls goofy to inform him that
his son is a criminal in the making a
mild exaggeration to say the least
goofy's fears about the division between
him and max come rushing to the surface
instead of talking to max about what
happened though goofy decides to spring
a road trip on him and insists on
leaving immediately given max had
already scheduled a date with roxanne
the move only alienates him further max
does plenty of questionable things
throughout the film not the least of
which is lying to roxanne about why he
can't keep their date and giving goofy
directions that will take them to los
angeles instead of goofy's planned
destination but while kids will notice
both goofy and max aren't making the
best choices adults will notice the
entire plot of the movie hinges on goofy
deciding to take max on an impromptu
vacation instead of the more mature
parenting choice of being open and
honest with his son
you forgot your lunch
have a good day
one of the oddest things about a goofy
movie is that none of the main teen
characters max pj and roxanne appear to
have mothers stranger still is that no
one comments on the fact that all three
kids are being raised by single fathers
given how little attention the movie
gives it many kids may miss the strange
coincidence however adults are likely to
find themselves wondering what happened
to the character's moms of course it's
possible roxanne has a mother that
simply doesn't appear in the film after
all we only see her overprotective
father when he opens the door for max on
the other hand starting with goof troop
and continuing into a goofy movie goofy
is known to be a single father and max's
mother is never mentioned sparking
plenty of fan speculation over the years
also sparking fan speculation is the
absence of pj's mom peg whose
disappearance is especially puzzling
because peg and pj's little sister
pistol were regular characters on goof
troop in a goofy movie no one mentions
either character and pete's
cross-country trip with pj appears to be
solely a father-son outing after 25
years of fans theorizing director kevin
lima clarified on twitter that while
pagan pistol appeared in early drafts of
the film they were eliminated to
emphasize the differences between pete
and pj and goofy and max
when a goofy movie was released in 1995
it featured plenty of technology but
while much of it was current for the
time only adults are likely to recognize
a lot of it today the camera goofy and
pete used to take pictures at a photo
studio in a big box store was outdated
even by 1995 standards but the cassette
tape and video camera that are a big
part of goofy and max's road trip were
still somewhat current in 1995. today
however kids may not be able to identify
the tape deck in goofy's car the
cassette he shoves into it or the tape
that shoots out as a cassette unravels
and although they'll recognize the video
camera even adults may think it's
strange that it appears to only record
in black and white what may spark the
most nostalgia from adults of a certain
age is the car cigarette lighter goofy
uses to heat up a can of soup for max
when they're trapped in their vehicle by
a rampaging bigfoot lighters used to
come standard in cars when cigarette
smoking was common and they remained
that way even after the public started
to realize the health risks however
today lighters are no longer found in
vehicles and the casual way goofy uses
his is likely to confuse anyone who
isn't old enough to remember when they
were as common in cars as cup holders
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you